hello hello hello children I play Count
Olaf and I've changed my look a lot my
name is shir means surely Count Olaf
[Applause]
[Music]
does this seem like a nightmare a bad
dream because that's the effect I was
going for if you are interested in
stories with happy endings that story is
streaming elsewhere I would advise all
our viewers to watch something more
pleasant to the stud
[Music]
I am Count Olaf your new guardian Miriam
and now we're orphans put them to work
in the mill mess economy children are
lucky to have a job at all
your first impression of me may be that
I am a terrible person but you haven't
the faintest idea you have to understand
he had a very terrible childhood don't
look so down having a very terrible
childhood right now okay our parents are
never coming back
we're all frightened Klaus mother and
father they made me promise to always
look after you let me keep my promise
you're finally safe now children just as
your parents wanted find your aunt
Josephine oh she can tell you everything
you need to know do you live with our
aunt just theme I am your aunt Josephine
[Music]
good morning i am stefano he is
afternoon and sure Count Olaf the only
reason I can Olaf hasn't told you limb
from limb is because he hasn't gotten
hold of your fortune
[Music]
you'll never get away with this
therefore she will be mine
carpe diem seize the children tease the
day twice a day
[Music]
who's smiling at me blue sky
violet Klaus and sunny were intelligent
children most everything that happened
to them was rife with misfortune and
despair your parents have perished in a
terrible fire perished means killed we
know what perished means hello hello
hello children I am Count Olaf your new
guardian do you know what this is it
looks like Al it's wrong it's a list a
list of chores we know you're trying to
steal a parent's fortune we have to get
out of this wretched place go back it
knows where it's safe and strangers
can't get you strangers where the boodle
their children will be destroyed
when the sand runs out that torture
isn't mine
I didn't realize the Sun went so quickly
I bought it online you're gonna need to
flip it a couple of times your parents
and I we used to develop our own secret
codes our parents devote secret codes in
my library you will find all the answers
that you need let's get to work
something strange is going on what's
there something my parents had it looks
like the tattoo Count Olaf has on his
ankle
my name is captain this man is really
Count Olaf in disguise aren't you smart
wherever you go I will hunt you down why
do you hate us so much because it's fun
we are setting out on a very top secret
expedition what do you say Baudelaires
are you in
[Music]
I'm taking you to prison well good luck
with that I'm armed
so my child's play adorable hmm it's a
harpoon gun
you